[Music]
Koizu 1 I also did a job,
and I say that I'm wearing Koizumi. 400 years later
, from 800, 413 Chanoyu saddles have been created.
I want to help with the culture of peace that I am proud of. In
my case, I went to study at the Urasenke's house for three years.
I think it was the first time for me to lay 60 degrees by country
. This is the value of black tea. It
is quite disadvantageous for women since Sato was able
to make tea
.
If it's just right, just
add hot water and use the
remaining amount as a pot again
and sing the tea again. I'll say a little greeting
to the customer.
If you like it while looking at Mr., and then
press the 袱 子 placed on the bottom of the next
one. In the case of one country, the soul is inside, so bring tea to peace
and make tea again in the same way.
It
seems that I was a very quiet child
, but I will never forget the day I had tea for the first time. It
was a very hot summer.
I was smelling incense from
someone, so I said he woke up in the hot weather. I
don't remember the sweets,
but I still remember only the tea
. The tea bowl is 8
morning glory.  The tea with flowers was
tea
. When I drank it, I was quiet in front of the teacher,
but as
soon as I got out, I heard that I was flirting.
It became so famous
that I asked that teacher to come to practice
. I'm glad that the body of the woman in this is also my sister
.
If not, anyone can believe it
[Music]
me